you wish for so many things that you
think I want that house
I want that car I love to go on that
holiday I wish I could lose weight I
want to look good I want that woman I
want that man imagine that your only
wish in the world wasn't anymore that
you want your baby to live
but when your baby dies
you wanna in your arms and you want it
to be peaceful
imagine that's the one thing that you're
wishing for in this world
that's all I could hope for
that was one New Hope
Ashley came welcome to the show thank
you
the last time that we were together in
person was tuped up Palace VIP
in Newcastle a very long time ago you're
joking last time that we were together
wow
a lot of things have changed
over the last few years
when we first became friends you were
coming out the back of doing reality TV
to next on the beach uh you were
starting businesses and doing a bunch of
other things
we haven't caught up since then
what's happened with life
I'd say
the Ashley Kane that you know
has disappeared banished
evaporated
um what's happened with life
I'd say that
I've probably gone through the most
traumatic experience that I believe
that a human being could
you know
always thought I was living the life
before
I thought
for a guy in his 20s it didn't get much
better
until I had my beautiful daughter Azalea
when I had that little girl
she made me understand what life truly
was
the crazy thing about it was you know
two months into becoming a daddy
something I always wanted to be
something to look forward to
something that actually made my life
Feel Complete for once
uh
I found out my daughter
had been diagnosed with AMR leukemia
finding out that
the most beautiful thing you've ever
created
the most precious and valuable thing to
you
has got a life-threatening illness not
just a life-threatening illness
or one of the most rare and aggressive
forms of cancer known
especially in a child that young
is something that not only breaks your
heart but feels like it takes your soul
away
I didn't really know what to do at that
point you know
I feel like I felt quite ashamed
when I found out that my daughter got
diagnosed
why
well I'll paint a picture we went to
hospital you know she got rushed into
Hospital
in an ambulance we suspected there
wasn't something right you know um
from probably
two weeks into it being born she had
like a stuffy nose
um
it was like cold flu symptoms but he was
drawing covet you know so you couldn't
just go to the doctors
um
the doctors said it'd be cold or flu you
know get um
one of those things that you pop a
baby's nose and suck the snot out my
grandma from the Caribbean wouldn't
allow that she said you know put you my
father knows and suck out yourself
um so that's what what I did
it didn't seem to to budge
then we found out that a stomach was
getting quite hard bloated
we thought it could be constipation or
colic that's what the doctor said
so we went with the doctors you know
but there's something about a parent's
instincts
that that tells you when your child
isn't right
then one morning my partner at the time
Sophia she found um a raised lump on
Azalea stomach it was like a bruise
when we told the dots about that they
kind of insisted that she needs to go to
hospital we rang one one they sent an
ambulance out straight away
so when we got to hospital at the time
um
you know she was having blood tests
which any parent will tell you when
their baby I saw a blood test is not
nice
you thinking that's kind of the worst
it's gonna get
but I I felt and I suspected that there
wasn't something right
um
when we were waiting for the news
it was crazy but something in my head
told me to stand up
even though I knew that I was going to
get told something
me standing up would give me a sign that
I knew how bad it was before they had to
open their mouths because I knew if it
was bad news they'd tell me to sit down
so I stood up and I waited and I waited
and when this team of
doctors came in
the first thing they told me to do was
sit down take a seat
then they told me that Azalea had Amal
leukemia
it was very aggressive she had a white
cell count of 200 at eight months old
yeah
um
and at that point I went into a State of
Shock you know I was upset
if I like the world when it's slow
motion
had no gauge of kind of I had no spatial
awareness I had no gauge of what was
really in front of me what wasn't of
reality if you would say
that's what the embarrassing part was
you know I didn't know how to take it
then my life changed you know from then
on from then hearing that we got
frustrating to Birmingham Children's
Hospital where we didn't go home
we didn't go home to get clothes we
didn't get home to pack anything we went
straight to Birmingham Children's
Hospital during coven as lady went
straight into
intensive care
they didn't think she'd make it
through the next day two days
um
I was in a room
probably a quarter third of the size of
this
I was sleeping
on the space on the floor probably about
this wide
um wasn't allowed to go outside to the
shops wasn't allowed to see family
friends
because it was covered
and that's when
my journey in life really started
foreign
what was your partner's response like
when she found out
she went straight to my daughter's side
with his instinct
protect your baby
you know the the crazy thing about it
was
the initial response for me is I
crumbled
my partner straight away is by my
daughter
and when we were in the hospital for the
first day
something correcting me
something corrected me it was like that
first night
lasted
a year
it was like I was in a Cell for a year
with time to think
I was thinking of all the things I could
do
to try and take this illness away
and no matter how many times I thought
and how many times it replayed it came
to the same conclusion
I couldn't take my daughter's illness
away
I couldn't swap positions
the only thing that I and my partner
could do
was control
the environment in which my daughter was
in
and if that was the only thing
that I or my partner could do
I was going to make sure that we did it
to the best of our ability
I know that babies are sensory beings
you know my daughter I might not have
understood what what we were saying
because but she could definitely pick up
on the environment that we created for
us our I pulled Sofia to the side you
know she was struggling at that point as
was I
and I said saf this room is Club 100. I
said when we step over this line
I said our baby will not see us cry
our baby will not see us upset
our baby will only see Smiles happiness
high energy a Fearless sense of belief
while we are here
is there no cure fix respite was there
even a note Point not not one percent
chance of survival or is it completely
terminal
so at that point you know
there was hope they
they didn't they didn't see a case of of
cancer like that and a baby so young
it doesn't usually happen
you know for the the initial plan was
um four cycles of chemotherapy
so you know you do cycle one
you're in hospital so let's say a weak
cycle of chemotherapy you're in hospital
for another two weeks to three weeks
then you get a couple of days at home
before you repeat cycle two cycle three
the thing it was with this area is she
was very young the chemotherapy
treatments are very harsh you know
um so they didn't know how she would get
on with them
it's true fire and Warrior she was she
absolutely smashed round one no side
effects
when it's around two
and there the cancer will come back very
early
so it was apparent after round two that
you know this normal cycle of four
rounds wouldn't work
unless we need a stem cell transplant
um
we found out at that point as well that
you know I'm half Sim Vincent and
Grenadines so half fancy half English my
partner is half Burmese half English
so my daughter had quite a rare match
which they told us at the time would be
hard to find a stem cell donor
there is lots of obstacles on this
journey
what
you know one thing remained and that was
hope and I was belief the crazy thing
was you know
when I heard that it was you know going
to be hard to find her a match
I contacted Anthony Nolan dkms straight
away
to create an Outreach campaign to get as
many donors as possible to register
in the hope
what I didn't understand was how much
support we had and we had 80 000 people
in one weekend registered to be a donor
for my daughter
probably north of a course of a million
within a week
um the special thing about that was that
you know not only were people reaching
out to be azaleas donor
for once Azalea found a donor they'd be
over a quarter of a million people in
that month that would go on top of the
people and that are helping other people
now
you know
the crazy thing was about that whole
journey is
I made a stand you know on the first day
that
I would be strong for my daughter you
know I'd be positive for my daughter
I'd keep hope faith and belief and I
would not let her see me sad
she would only see Daddy smiling
because I thought I had to be strong for
her
what turned out
and what what was apparent very quickly
where she was that strong
she was that brave
she radiated that much love
did she fueled not only me but my
partner
and my family
for hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people around the world at
that time during a global pandemic
she was incredible she was special
you've said that you're being purposely
strong you don't want to step into the
ward where your daughter's being kept
and show weakness
but what happens when you're away from
her what happens when she's asleep what
happens when you do go home to get
clothes
what's life like for you what's the
inside of the texture of your mind like
during this time when you're not with
her
you get scared
you know
one thing I try and not explain to
people about life in a minute you know
when it gets tough
I kind of fire back with
imagine fearing
every second of every single day
about the next minute that comes along
might be the last minute that you see
your daughter breathing
that she's alive
imagine going to bed at night
and not knowing that when you wake up in
the morning if your daughters still
going to be breathing or not
over and over and over again
that's hard
you know
I am
I had to sleep in the hospital
I had to sleep there
I got so scared of the night time
that I had to be there in hospital at
night
because
I didn't trust the night time
I didn't trust it
I always feared that something would
happen in the night so I had to be there
that meant that I didn't really sleep
which is probably why I don't have to
sleep that much now you had observations
at observations sorry every 20 30
minutes
you got beep beep beep nurses coming in
nap is knee changing
I'm staring at that bed staring at night
making sure she's okay
and subsequently you know
the most beautiful time I used to feel
was in the morning and it was crazy I
used to open my eyes and wake up yeah
I used to look to the right and my
daughter would already be looking at me
and as soon as I'd opened my eyes she'd
have the biggest smile on the face then
I used to open their blinds I used to
put my music on straight away I used to
get it changed and we start dancing
I know it's the whole room arms all day
and dance
because I was grateful for another
opportunity to spend with that I didn't
have like had probably two channels on
the TV you can imagine what them
channels were
I didn't have hardly any reception on my
phone
I wasn't now to go to the shops I was a
Nazi family wasn't RC friends
but I had something worth more than
absolutely anything and drawing the most
painful and traumatic time of my life
I had the most beautiful time of my life
which will never ever leave me which I
will always look back to and appreciate
and hold on to and be grateful for
how long does this go on for
so
month three they were in the hospital
was when Azalea had a stem cell stem
cell transplant
again you know
they thought she wouldn't make it
through
it's quite a big procedure you would
think that you know stem cell transplant
I thought you know you're going to this
big room there's a lot of machines
there's electronic arms all this Tech
basically just laying there laying in
her Hospital in her bed story and um
they just put the new stem cells into a
viral central line and a chest and that
was done
there was a waiting game and they
thought it'd probably be you know
two to three months before she's fully
in graphed
three weeks done no side effects
we thought that that was going to be the
end of the line effectively we were
prepared to go home
you know
uh
I mean the Nazis did a stellar job and
so did we as parents um I mean that room
was kept Immaculate as alien was kept
Immaculate if that meant she had to have
a nappy changed every 10 minutes that's
what we did
so after she engrafted you know we
stayed in hospital for another period of
time and then you know we thought that
she was going to be
in remission we thought we were going to
be outpatient and we thought it would be
coming to bring the bar
so we went home for a couple of days no
we went home for a week
while she had a
her Lumber puncher done that was to test
if there was any Romanian leukemia or
he'd come back
they seem to be fine
so we got called into hospital that day
to go in and ring the bell
imagine this has been like
four months no five months
four or five months of being in hospital
you know fearing
the worst
and then we're going into finally ring
the bar
this is a great point for me because you
know
when I had a daughter I kind of got
myself to a position with work
that I was going to be like a full-time
daddy effectively you know they say like
a momager I was gonna be a dadager you
know I was going to be there I was
planning my life for my little girl she
was my everything
and it felt like this was the start and
this is where
you know my journey was going to lead to
my daughter now I was even planning on
you know
telling her you're asking her what you
like to do when she's at school
you know what would you like to do if
you didn't have to go to school today
and her telling me and me going to the
school making up an excuse why she's got
to come home and tell her not to tell
her mom
so we went into to ring the bell and um
just as she had her checkups done
the nurses line the corridor and the
doctor's ready to clap and uh I mean
oncologist came in
and said we've got some bad news
um as though he's relapsed
which is relapsed
in a terrible way and the cancers come
back very aggressive and she's got
tumors have come back in their stomach
her lungs her spleen
her kidneys
and we don't really know what to do
at this point uh
sorry
at this point um I had to kind of gather
staff
and I had to say that you know
that's not good enough for me
I said my little girl is my entire world
I said I'd Die For Her
I said I would do anything
for her to be dishonest
and that means that I am not taking no
for an answer
I am not taking that you don't know what
to do
I am not taking the fact that you want
us to go home
she asked for for too long and she's
fought far too hard and we have fought
for too long and we are fought far too
hard for this to be the end
and that was a point where we started to
look for treatment abroad you know we
were looking for
therapy which is targeted to
chemotherapy
which you know doesn't obliterate the
body but it targets certain T sounds to
remove
um the leukemia
we found out that in them there was two
places in America that did it but they
didn't treat children under two years of
two years of age
um
there was a place in China
but they weren't letting anybody in due
to covid
so we found one last place which was
Singapore
um
this treatment was going to cost north
of a million pound 500 000 had initial
deposit
500 000 pounds to see the treatment
through and then obviously you have the
time in hospital to Monitor and test or
if you have to go for another round
again so you're looking at far north of
a million pound
it wasn't August poor but I didn't have
a million pound you know
um so we
we decided that you know that's what
we're gonna do we spoke to the hospital
we you know sent samples and then it was
a pointer starting to GoFundMe which we
did
um
I think the GoFundMe campaign actually
raised a million pound within about five
hours
which was incredible I think that that
goes to show
of how much of an effect Azalea had on
the world
and how incredible
people actually are
you know social media can be seen as
such a cynical place
but the whole time during our journey in
hospital it was in a reminder of me of
how beautiful the people are in this
world as well
um so we raised the money
which is absolutely incredible
unlock every stage of this journey
every moment that seems like he's going
to be so happy was followed by a bank
the day after we raised the money the
doctors and the oncologist came in to
say that they now found tumors on this
80's brain
which would mean that she can't travel
which also meant that she was
too young to have targeted radiotherapy
which also meant that if they wanted to
do
a lumber puncher
a chemotherapy into a spinal cord they
couldn't
because it would risk
on the tumors of rupture
which meant that um
they say they had to go home
now
you think that
finding out your daughter's got
a rare and aggressive form of cancer is
hard
oh yeah
you think that six months
in a hospital room
fearing
that you're gonna lose your daughter
every minute of every day would be hard
wouldn't you
think they're hearing your daughter had
relapsed after the hopes of taking her
home would be hard
when they tell you that you've got to
take your daughter home
for her to pass away
because there's nothing else they can do
us when stuff gets really hard
because I was effectively taking my
daughter home to die
I didn't know how she was gonna die
I didn't know if she was going to be in
pain
I didn't know if it was going to be
today tomorrow or a week's time but I
knew
that my daughter was gonna die at home
that's hard
that's when everything started to get
really dark
yeah
up until this point you've been able to
try and have
some sort of change
having put in some way
oh
that's it
appreciation
of what's in front of you and hope
that's all I had
that was enough
that was more than enough
I didn't realize
how much
and how important that was until I
didn't have it anymore
you know
I can't really explain the feeling but
imagine imagine
these lights in this room
they just go off
in your whole world looks like this dark
gray tone that's how we're seeing things
that's not an analogy of how things were
when they told me I had to take my
daughter home my whole body went heavy
you felt like I was carrying a rucksack
with 30 with 50 kilos in it and that's
how I was walking around
I felt like I couldn't see colors
I felt like things were moving slow
really slow
and my body my head and my heart felt
constant pain
you wish for so many things like that
you think
I want that house
I won that car I love to go on that
holiday
I wish I could lose weight I want to
look good
I want that woman I want that man
whatever the case may be
imagine that your only wish in the world
wasn't anymore
that you want your baby to live
but when your baby dies
you wandering your arms and you want it
to be peaceful
imagine that's the one thing that you're
wishing for in this world
that's all I could hope for
that was one New Hope
he got to the point where
when Azalea was crying tears were blood
scary
quite scary
well
they thought when Azalea was at home she
probably last two days
talk about three weeks typical she was a
fighter
she was a warrior she was a lion she was
she always defied the odds
and one thing I'll always be thankful to
her forwards there was one night in
particular
and when we started going home
that's when you could really see the
illness physically
it sounds crazy doesn't it she's got you
know an NG tube she's got two Central
lines going in the chest but
you couldn't see a poorly baby this lady
was that beautiful that strong that full
of life
apart from the wires
she looked like a healthy baby but when
we take her when we took her home sorry
that was when you could see the evidence
of the cancer really having an effect
and it was one night in particular where
I didn't think she was going to wake up
in the morning
and I remember I went to bed with Sophia
and Azalea between us
and ours opened in the morning
but as our eyes opened her breathing
became labored
and I knew
I knew that that
this was going to be the final morning
at that point we didn't need to put any
monitors on her
because we knew that no matter how much
we monitor our
or what assistance we call
this was it
so the only thing we made sure we did as
parents
is made sure that zadie was rested in
our arms
and I just remember
one
two
two three
four
one
two three
four
five
six
seven
one
two three
four
five six
seven
eight
nine
ten
eleven
and she didn't Breathe Again
you know when you say uh
the last time you see me in top top
what's going on
whole heap of [__] me and
it's been hard
it's been hard you could have locked me
in the south for the rest of my life
you could have tortured me
you could have asked me to put a knife
in my neck right now from here to here
and cut it
you could have took my mom my dad my
family
do not take my daughter
you know
then that's where I've been
that's what I've had to go through
that's the the trauma that I'm still you
know battling with on a day-to-day basis
now
replays in my mind I relive it
and it's tough mate
it's tough
what does this do to your relationship
with your partner
that's interesting it's a question I
wouldn't usually answer
I tell you what
it all starts off
with being in hospital yeah
so effectively for four months no
six months out of our relationship
I'd be in the hospital room
she'd be in the hotel room across the
road
you know we'd spend half the day there
each
and we'd walk down we'd walk across
hello how are you
what's up
it's hard
how's Xavier
she's doing well today she's not doing
well today
okay
that's how it was
we were United
in the fact that
we're both trying to be strong for each
other
and in doing so we'll be strong for
Xavier
when we lost his area
it's difficult and I'll tell you what
it's difficult because
you build a relationship
I enjoy enjoying each of this company
right you're intrigued in that person
are excited about what holiday you're
gonna go on what things you can do you
have interesting fun conversations
you probably
you know get a lot of time to enjoy
sexual relations all of these things
that build a strong healthy relationship
you know I've seen my partner for
five minutes long
one minute a day
for six months
when our daughter passed away
we didn't wanna
go for food
we didn't want to think about
what holiday we were going on at the end
of the year
we weren't
interested in experimenting in the
bedroom
we were suffering extreme trauma
now
I
knew what path I needed to go on
you know
and
I knew that no matter what I had to
fulfill it
you know
and the thing is and the only thing that
I can say is
the crazy thing about morning Sophia's
relationship is
even though we are no longer together
we have more Unity
loyalty
respect
and commitment to each other now
than we ever did before
because of the love for our daughter
because of the need to evoke positive
change
in fighting cancer in children
and because of the fact that we want to
honor
our daughter's time here
and their legacy
and for me
we didn't split up because I wanted to
find another partner
we didn't split because she wanted to
we didn't split up because we didn't
love each other anymore
support each other because we weren't
there for each other
foreign
trying to fulfill a relationship
with that much trauma becomes difficult
but where that became difficult
we stood by each other
we've never left each other's side
I will love her until the day I die she
dies because she gave me
the most Incredible Gift Anyone on this
Earth could have given me
I caravana I respect her and I will
always be there for her and I believe
she would always be there for me
but I think
it damaged things and I don't think it
only damaged things
for us in our relationship
but I think he's left permanent damage
for me to even think of getting in a
relationship going forward
have you tried to have another
relationship Center no
I haven't got the time
it doesn't really it doesn't really
bother me
that's a genuine truth
it sounds crazy knowing me all them
years ago and what I was like
of the force of nature
back then but it's not something
that I think about on a day-to-day basis
it's not something that I look to the
Future and think that's what I want
it's definitely something that I can't
I'm not ignorant and naive enough to say
that it wouldn't happen
but it's definitely not in my sights at
the minute let's put it that way do not
get lonely
no
why
why number one if I'm just gonna be
normal I've got an Incredible family
something I thank God for every single
morning
incredible beautiful family
number two
sophistic in my life you know
but the main reason is
because I'm aware of my mission
and I'm super focused
laser focused on it
and
I'm kind of aware that nobody
is as passionate as me on my specific
Mission as I am
I'm aware that you can't have somebody
hold your hand through your whole
journey while you're chasing it
I'm aware that
sometimes you need to spearhead
something
in order to pave the way for it to get
done
I'm aware that you know I am seven days
a week I am 18 hours a day I sleep five
hours a night maximum if that
all of these things are lonely things
and I'm fine with that
so it doesn't really play a part in my
life
worrying about that aspect of it
right now you're focused on
doing things which we'll get on to
after Azalea passes away
do you immediately get galvanized into
action or
do you have to go through darker moments
before that
should I tell you what was the
life-changing moment for me
having to write my daughter's eulogy
it was something
and it was one of the
Rama does eulogy was one of the hardest
things I've ever had to do
number one
because what father
expects to speak at his daughter's
funeral
you know
it's about thinking about
you can't even comprehend it you know
so I was trying to write and trying to
create a a
masterpiece that could
honor and commemorate my daughter while
going through so much trauma
that's hard
it was also hard because I thought that
no matter how beautiful my words are how
powerful they are
how much pain is in them
it will never truly be hard to reflect
how amazing that she was
so I knew that I had to really dig deep
in that moment and reflect
so I could write something and not only
write it but I have the courage to stand
up and speak it on her day
invited my daughter's udg
I realized
the person
that I wanted to be
and I needed to be
I realized about all the things that I
wanted to do going forward and that I
needed to do going forward
and it made me understand what it was
going to take
and that's why I don't think there's
much compromise in my life now
I said that you know
that my life my daughter was you know
compressed to a room in a hospital
I'm a God fear a man
so I now believe that my door's in
heaven and I believe she's watching down
on me
if that is the case I said I want to
take her all around the world with
nothing but Daddy power to the top of
Every Mountain to the bottom of every
Valley along every road across every
ocean I said I'll take you there
and that was a life-changing moment for
me
but
I can't lie you know
I found drink
you know when she passed away
I would drink whiskey and I'd drink more
whiskey and I drink more whiskey
and you know I think at first I thought
it was going to numb the pain
if anything it made me more emotional
I thought that maybe if I would drink
I could give my mind a rest because all
it felt was uncontrollable
painful
trauma that just infested and riddled my
body and my mind
and eventually I was just drinking just
to knock myself out
I would drink to that point
where I was knocked out
just as a way to sleep
I remember something happened you know I
woke up one morning
and I felt upset
I thought
if this is the man
that my daughter is looking down on as
her daddy
I feel [__] ashamed
I feel embarrassed
so then I decided to get the [__] up
I start honoring my promise that I made
to her that day and I made to myself
and I'm
have a look back
what was the darkest moment that you
went through
personally
it depends
you talking about personally in terms of
you know
them telling me I've got to take my
daughter home are you talking about
personally
like
cut my doors the last burst in my arms
are you talking personally
you know since her passing
there's so many moments that were sort
of that taught me to literally the pits
of how a human being can feel
that when you're at the bottom it's hard
to quantify which one's worse and which
one's not
a lot of people would have tried to exit
a lot of people would have maybe
considered
taking their own life
we were attempted to do that
it's uh
it's hard to find a reason to want to be
here when you feel like everything
that you ever dreamed of
in a little ball it was called Azalea
it's been ripped away from you
you know I couldn't think of anything
worse than losing a child and
for the minute I'll wake up in the
morning
I turn around
and I see a picture of her
that's traumatic for the moment I open
my eyes
at the you know at the start of the
evening
I'll go down to my daughter's resting
place
to say good night and say my prayers and
that's how I see my daughter every
single day
that's traumatic
to look down and realize that she's in
the ground
you know
and there was a specific point
where
are they even see he was after I ran a
marathon you know that year I'd done the
1100 mile cycle for London to Jonah
Grove so I've done
The Three Peaks in Cycles 700 miles in
between I've done 109 mile
ultra marathon I don't find my things in
five days in five different cities in
five different countries then I cycle
one thousand eight hundred miles from
London to Paris to Geneva to Rome then I
got back in a couple of days later I ran
the marathon and that was like the end
of that year
I had a couple days off
[__] me was that a bad idea
Assam
and I thought
no matter
how much
I do
for other people
I will never ever
get what I want at the end of it
all these miles over and all these malls
are cycle all these occasions I give up
like Christmas
I'll give them my Christmas period I
feel like after I've done all that in
the hope that you know something's gonna
happen
I sit there at the end and I'm still
empty-handed
so I remember waking up one morning and
I just must have sat in my hotel room
for hours
and then it was time to go home
and I thought I don't want to go home
so I checked out the hotel
[Music]
and I walked
and I walked and I walked and I walked
it was near the docks I remember
to a point where there was nobody around
you know no people
no traffic
just me and a bridge
and um
I stood there for a second
and I just thought of my mum and I
thought
you know before I do what I'm gonna do
I need to message my mom
I remember writing this message
thank you my mom for everything
telling her how much of a beautiful
person that she is
how I couldn't have got to the point
where I've got to now after what I've
been through without her
and that I love her
more than anything in this world
and then I put my phone on my bag
and I crowned up onto the wall
and I stood there
for a couple of seconds
it's taken in the air
and what I was about to do
I'll tell you something now I ain't
scared of dying
I'm not
and it wasn't an emotional decision to
jump
I just felt like I had enough
and the next minute
I hit the deck on my back
not that way but this way and I looked
up
and it was like six riot police
Ahmed up everything
and I remember getting up yeah and I
looked around and in my head it was
weird it was crazy and I remember just
scrapping and I'm scrapping these police
but these are big dudes they're like
Riot band police or all the gear on yeah
and were throwing hands I'm scrapping
but as I'm scrapping officers they're
crying
I'm on a bridge one minute ready to jump
that way next room I'm on my back and
the next minute I'm in a melee with Riot
police that are crying yeah
eventually you know
we were calm
I got my cuffs on you know
come in the back of the van
I'm still a bit out of source
and the whole thing
I can't believe that I'm in a van and
you know not on the floor either side of
the drop
and when the police officers goes to get
in the back of the van with me
and the other police officer said no you
can't he's too volatile you know he's
dangerous
and the guy went nah I gotta get in
and this police officer was in tears
and he's saying
I Know Who You Are
you inspire me
you've done so much for this world that
you can't do this
hey Tommy's name
his name is Jesus
imagine that
imagine that I'm a God-fearing man you
know
I believe I pray
that's what gives me hope
and this police officer that pulled me
down his name was Jesus and
from that moment on
you know
that never became a part of my life
anymore after that moment
is very humbling
it was another embarrassing moment
because
one thing that I choose to do in my life
is is I
don't want to hide anything
I don't want it to be no skeletons in my
closet
I don't want to feel like people are
talking about me or know things about me
that I haven't said myself
I believe in order to be able to move on
from something
or with something first you need to
accept that something and acknowledge
that something and then you have the
ability to carry it forward
so I had to go home and I had to tell
you know my family
and my friends what just happened what
was that conversation like
personally
it was embarrassing
I felt ashamed
for so many different reasons
pick up to this point everybody knew how
much pain I was in everybody knew how
much I miss my daughter
but everybody also
knew how strong I was
you're doing these Thousand Miles rides
you're running the marathons you're the
guy that's doing the things well I was a
beacon of strength not only for you know
people that follow me but for my family
you know because I was strong everybody
became strong
everybody looked to me for strength
everybody came around me for strength
for Hope for belief
and I'd just done that
it was painful
because
you know
the realization for me
that I nearly
out of my own choice
put my mum through a feeling that I'm
going through now
is bad
did she see the message before you got
home to talk to her
but not in that message that I say that
I was standing on the bridge
do you think that there was something
wrong
probably yeah
you know it was a difficult moment for
everybody around me at that point
and you know what's also very difficult
it's earning
that trust
that respect back
not in terms of you know people loving
you because they they might always love
you
earning that trust and the respect back
that people aren't scared every time you
walk out the door
that's difficult as a man
do you think that they're still worried
about you
I think
more so at the minute well listen
I'm very emotionally intelligent yeah I
understand things I'm also very honest
and transparent so I think the people
around me have a clear understanding of
how I'm feeling a lot of the time and
especially as more things happen or I
complete more challenges or I experience
more of a new emotions
I find ways to speak about them I find
ways to explain them
I find ways to you know deliver them to
people around me
for me number one to get the weight off
my shoulders but also to help other
people to not feel like they're alone
maybe they feel like that you know
so
I like to think now that they don't
worry about that aspect of things
because
I think I've proved a lot since that day
I've achieved a lot since that day I've
spoke a lot since that day
and that day made me realize something
that that wasn't the way
sometimes on this journey a lot of
things are confusing Chris
you know a lot of like a lot of the time
in my life
after that event happened I was confused
about a lot of things
the world wasn't the same imagine a lot
of people yeah
a lot of people that go they go oh God
that week's flew by
that year has gone so quick
I feel
every second of every single day my time
is is like this now
and I spend a lot of time inside my own
head I spend a lot of time
self-analyzing situations feelings
emotions I work out you know what makes
me feel a certain way I work out the
best way to combat that I find out you
know ways of increasing my mental
strength
I'm like this all the time and I also
speak to a lot of different people as
well so I kind of try and work myself
out based on experiences
um I remember after that moment
again because I thought I can't believe
I nearly did that you know I can't
believe I nearly put my mom through the
same pain I'm going through
because I was sure you know after that
moment and after the signs of why it
didn't happen that I needed to be here
that I do have a purpose
I thought you know what Asha
what you what are you most scared of in
this world now
and I'm not scared about much you know
I'm not I'm not scared of dying it
doesn't phase me
you know I thought I'm scared of heights
though I don't like heights
I thought I suffer from vertigo when I
get high if I put my hand over a balcony
like that I feel like I'm going to drop
my phone everything gets weird
so I thought all right and that's you
want to jump
you jump properly
so a week after I nearly took my own
life
I
went abroad and I got my skydiving
license and I jumped 20 times in a week
I have a plane
at my most vulnerable stage of my life
mentally
I went and did something which would
challenge me more than anything else I
could ever think of doing
and
it was one of the best things I ever did
very humbling
but again
it showed me the growth and the
importance of stepping outside your
comfort zone
and the power that comes along with it
why are you doing all of this stuff now
why are you running all of these races
you explain to me about your daily
routine of a lunch
which puts David Goggins for a bit of a
run as well all of these extreme events
the things that you're putting your body
through the lack of sleep the daily
routine
why
who's the person that you care about the
most in this world
name me one
my mom
yeah
so if someone
came
and took your mom
and put on a cloud in the sky
and the only way that you could see her
again
is if you built a tower
High Enough
to be able to bring it back down
or to be with her again
would you wake up tomorrow and wonder
why you
or would you get building
I believe wow
I hope
that there is a heaven
I believe that if there is
my daughter is there
and all of her that much
that the hope of Heaven
and the hope of her being there
motivates me to be as good a person as I
can be
and Achieve as much in this world
to help others
and to make her proud
that in the end
I hope that I've built enough steps to
see her again
I hope
and my drive purely is
that when I'm on my deathbed
I can have five seconds of Peace before
I take my last breaths
knowing that I've done enough on this
Earth
that they open the gates of Heaven for
me but it's when I reach there and
that's genuinely the truth are you
concerned that
some of the events that the approach
that you're taking
raising money you have a foundation you
are wearing orange and cycling around
the world doing stuff stand up paddle
boarding canoeing whatever it might be
are you concerned that
that might be causing you to not cope to
not be able to
integrate the emotions that you're going
through that rather than just using it
for good it's also you being able to run
away from facing
more of those demons
I love it when people ask me that or
tell me that I think that might be the
case it's very interesting
I would say to anybody that asks me that
knows nothing
about losing a child and there's nothing
about the reason why we choose to do
this
I have never ever
run away
from the pain of losing a child
I immerse myself in it
I never want the pain of losing my
daughters to go away because that pain
is the only time I truly feel love
I embrace that pain
I use that pain to push me further and
further
and the reason why I challenge myself
and the reason I push myself
is because when I'm feeling
this physical pain and when I have to
take myself
to another level to complete one of
these challenges that is when I connect
with her the most
that's when I feel like she's truly with
me
that's when I feel like I could look up
and say
your baby
we did it again
so
I would say the polar opposite
when you look at my life yeah
I
you know I'm the founder and Trustee of
my daughter's Foundation
that means that every day we are talking
about
either children
that are no longer getting treatment on
the NHS that we're trying to give money
to
we're talking about new trials or new
treatments that are available which we
can invest money to new equipment
the foundation's also got a PhD fund now
which funds new talent and research
coming into Childhood Cancer
I visit kids with cancer I go towards
where my daughter actually was actually
going back into the same room that my
daughter was you know on a weekly basis
I
visit my daughter at a resting place
every single night
but I'm at home
I raise money
I speak to her every day I push myself
to the absolute limit I not only try and
create a more positive and safer space
for parents as well
that are going through the same thing as
me but people that are actually
suffering with their Mental Health
I guess
I'm not running away from anything
I'm running directly and head on into
all of my pain
into all of my trauma
into all of the things they're trying to
hold me down
and I've run head on into it because
I feel like I found a way to harness
that
to push me further than I would have
ever gone before
what would you say to
anybody that's grieving now
that's going through that process one of
the things that we can all guarantee in
life is that
the people that we love
some of them are going to pass away
before us
and we're going to have to deal with
that process as somebody that has spent
an awfully long time sat in the saddle
of a bike sat in a hospital Ward
reflecting on Grief
what do you wish that you'd known or
what would you tell other people
I'm going to try and smile when I speak
about this it seems like a crazy thing
to say right
um
one thing they certain in this world is
you know everyone that's born is gonna
die
that means that
every single person on this planet is
going to experience some form of grief
I've never been a person to run away
from those emotions
you know and I never believe that you
know it gets easier people always say
grief gets easier
I believe that the circle of grief
always stays the same
I just believe that we grow stronger
around it
I would always advise people to
talk
about their loved ones that they've lost
I would always encourage people to
settle into every single emotion that
they're feeling and not try and hide it
or not try and run away from it
I would say to people that you know what
even though your grief is painful and
even though your grief hurts
it can also be the most beautiful
Time of Your Life the most beautiful
moments that you have left
because all the pain that you're feeling
now
is because of beautiful memories of the
person that you love and the person that
you've lost
I think that
my grief has become a part of my life
and like I say I've never tried to run
away from it
I've never tried
to compress it
I don't even wish that it's not there
because I am quite happy and settled and
grieving for the rest of my life because
I know that I grow stronger every single
day around that grief I know that within
my grief
is my purpose I know that within my pain
is my power I know that from my struggle
I found my strength
and I don't think people
should hide that you know one thing that
I do I remember going on the run the
other day yeah and there's this circuit
and it I went to this circuit where
people run it's like a five mile Loop
and everyone's like oh how far are you
running today you know 5K whatever I
said I've you know
30 miles to like
30k and 30 miles
and I went to this um this tackle shop
because it was by Lake you know fishing
and I said can I leave my bags here they
said I'm about to shut up in a minute
sorry
and I went yeah and I've told him a
little bit about the journey and anyway
I started running I was about two and a
half miles in
no there's about two miles in
and I thought
[__]
I told him I was running
I told him why I was running but I
didn't tell him my daughter's name
and I turned back and I ran two miles
back yeah as fast as I could just use
about to lock up I mean by the way mate
you know what I want my daughter's name
is Azalea and he went
okay beautiful name yeah thanks and then
I went back into my run I ran two miles
extra just because I had to run back and
tell him my name
that's because that's important to me
I think it's important to also normalize
you know this topic of grief
we're gonna experience it so the subject
shouldn't be taboo
just like mental health you know grief
can fall into that category people talk
about anxiety people talk about
depression grief falls into that
and grief causes anxiety causes
depression
you know the root cause of the grief is
trauma it all falls into mental health I
think it's a part that we should talk
about because I found out and one thing
that I know now is when people had lost
somebody before
I was um
I was a criminal of kind of thinking
it's really awkward to be around that
person I don't know what to say I don't
want to make them upset I don't want to
offend them yeah
what I find out now is
those people
really do want to talk about the
memories they have people do really want
to say the person's name of the person
they lost
people do want to reminisce and relive
those good times
but it's hard to find people around them
that will allow that
So Not only would I say to the people
that have loved them and lost that they
should talk about their loved ones and
not run away from it I'd also say if you
want to be a good friend or a good
family member be there for that person
to listen to
what are the events that you are focused
on
over the coming years
so what this year or Okay
um
so like I said in my Unity I said to the
top of every mile into the bottom of
every Valley along every road across
every ocean I mean one of the big goals
for me is
it's not in the planning yet but I know
I'll do it it's um I want to climb the
seven highest mountains in the seven
continents
the whole point of that is to tell my
daughter I love her from the seven
highest parts of this world
you know
but this year you know next weekend I've
got 125 mile kayak race which is 24 to
30 hours that should be fun
but this is It's just training really
for the Thousand Mile card race I've got
in July which is supposed to be the
world's toughest survival endurance race
it's from Canada to the Arctic Circle to
Alaska
and it's completely unsupported so you
kayak for 18 hours a day
find a place to pull in
pitch up return sleep for four hours
get back on the next day you've got an
hour to eat obviously the problem is
with it being unsupported is
if you're on a river that's 10 miles
wide or five miles wide and you go in
you ain't coming out
if you're near the side and you go in
hypothermia kicks in
it will take them two days to come and
rescue you
too late
if you happen to preach your tent
there are a bunch of grizzly bears
it's game over
so there's fatalities every year
the guy said how many people do that
I don't know
how many people enter the race you don't
know I don't know literally you want to
know how my life is
I literally got a call
um of you know one of my friends and she
said that she's got PT who's ex-military
who's into kayaking and he wants to go
big this year and he wants to complete
the Yukon 1000.
he hasn't got a partner for the race and
I'm actually due to him and I said that
you know
you're driven you're determined you
don't quit
and he said let's speak to you
I picked to the phone didn't know him
spoke to him he said you want to do this
and
hundreds of things flash performing
before my answer quick like that done
I thought to myself you know
I don't know this guy from Adam
I don't know if we'll get on that's a
minor problem
I also thought I could go out there and
not come back
that's a huge possibility
but I remember when I lost my daughter
yeah and
this goes on to this point of making
this decision
I'd spend you know six months in
hospital
Adam Watts and earn no money when my
daughter passed it wasn't okay it was
the first thing I wanted to do to go
back to work and earn money
that being said I was getting offered a
lot of money you know I was getting off
a 20 000 pound to post a picture on
Instagram
I said no
I didn't want to promote this table
because I wouldn't have this table
I was thinking my life is that important
for me going forward and I'm a man on
the mission that if I take money to
promote this table now
how about when I actually have a message
that I want to say to the people people
ain't gonna be able to take me seriously
so I went into a bit of a financial
crisis you know
I refused to take money there wasn't
good money I believe that not every bit
of money that crosses this Palm is good
winning I don't need to snatch and take
it
you know I was seven months in to quit
an alcohol
I was out running cycling and swimming
ridiculous miles a day for nothing
just because I wanted to be outside and
I wanted to be with my daughter you know
I was
doing these challenges I was right I was
working on the foundation I was raising
money for these kids I was speaking to
people that were suffering from their
mental health I was doing all of this
just for free even though I had nothing
you know and I remember at that point I
got down on my knees and I said to God I
was like I'm I'm ready
you know I'm at the point now uh you
know
I can't even really put I can't put a
roof over my head you know I can't put a
roof over my head you know I'm
struggling to to put food on the table
to eat you know
I've gave up this money which isn't good
money
of sacrifice my time for this Foundation
to raise money to raise awareness I've
gave up drinking I don't go out
please
please I'm ready
and that's when the chances started
coming
so when I was on the official Zoom
meeting to to you know pitch myself to
get this race and the race organizer
said night you know are you ready to to
go and he told me he's going to be
fatalities every year
I thought
if I don't say yes
then what is that saying to my daughter
during that talk in a Unity why is that
saying to God when I got down on my
knees with open hands
but most importantly what is that saying
to myself
when I'm brushing my teeth and I'm
looking at the man that's looking back
in the mirror before I go to bed
so I said
that's [__] God
Bring It On
because you know when else is my
daughter gonna get to go from Canada to
the Arctic Circle to Alaska eh
when am I going to get that chance again
and I believe that you know if we go and
we come back boy I'm a whole different
level
I've raised awareness I've raised funds
I put my money around my mouth was it I
put my money where my mouth is
um and if I don't
she obviously needs me back
and that's good enough for me
what's the message that you want people
to take away beyond your love your
daughter beyond
your relationship with that and that
grief
God there is so many messages within it
number one you know
I would always say to people you know in
this world if you ask they'll say if you
ask a healthy man you know what he wants
you know talk about cars and talk about
houses you'll talk about women he'll
talk about all of these things
if you ask them an unhealthy man or a
sick man what he wants he'll say one
thing and that's how
you know one of my
strongest messages to people is
appreciate what you have right in front
of you
you know I'm living a life now where the
only one thing that I want in this world
has been snatched away from me but
having said that when she was here in
front of me in that hospital room I
loved and appreciated every single
second and I loved and appreciated that
moment so much
that
that will fill my heart for the rest of
my life
so I would always say to people
appreciate what you have right in front
of you
I would also like to say that you know
no matter
what you are going through in life
how sad you are
how much pain you're feeling
the trauma that you're going through
you are strong enough to see another day
and it's not about being 100
every single day
Spa just showing up
that's what I do
no matter what the odds no matter how
I'm feeling I show up every single day
and by showing up every single day
and doing what I do
I believe
it gives me more than happiness
I think happiness is rubbish I don't
think there's no such thing as happiness
I believe we have
happy moments
I believe we have happy memories
and I believe we have happy places
I don't believe there's any such thing
as happiness because there's so many
things in this world on a day-to-day
basis that want to go bang and take the
wind out of your sails
okay
but what I choose to do is rather than
looking out for temporary forms of
validation or things that I can get to
make me happy
I've become competent in doing what's
necessary
so the fact that no matter what is up
against me I believe that not only can I
do it
or have the courage to do it
I have the strength to see it through
and then afterwards
I build self-worth
I'll be build self-belief
I have fulfillment which I believe far
outweighs happiness
I think that
most of people's mental health issues or
a lot of people's mental health issues
sorry these days
is because they have no self-worth
I believe they have no self-confidence
especially men
I believe that they're they're looking
for Saturday night going out to pick up
a drink and try and find a woman
to make me feel happy
rather than turning up every single day
one thing that changed about my life is
I start every day the same
I wake up every single morning
that drunken man
it was ashamed of himself
as his door watched down from heaven and
what I choose to do is
earn my respect every single day
and for me
from other people that might look has
been very intense for me it works
because I go to bed every single evening
and I look in the mirror and I just
think
you know what you did all right today
what's a typical day look like for you
typical day okay so she said yesterday
so yesterday I
got up at 5am because I had to travel
back from another city
um I got back about six
and then I didn't have time to have
breakfast because my two running
Partners wanted to go out on a run
so I stopped off at a petrol station
got a flapjack and we had a 20 mile run
um I finished the 20 mile run
and then I had to go and do my strength
and conditioning session because I need
to look after my body so it's not
lifting weights it's just working on all
those little shitty areas to stop
getting injuries so I've done an hour
snc
there
um then I did an hour of stretching and
Mobility
because
unable to recover
then I went back home and I did
two three hours of meetings in terms of
the foundation in terms of my new book
that I have coming out in terms of a new
show that I have to go on
then I did an hour
on the kayak ERG
and then I went and swam a thousand
meters
and then
I got back and I carried on work
before Tom was up until
I think I went to sleep probably about
12 o'clock
then I got up at 5am to travel to get my
session in before I traveled here today
to do this I my my days Blended to so
many different projects it's like I've
got a game for my this is this is how
varied it could be I've got you know a
new TV show that's out at the minute
exploring the different face of grief so
there's a lot of work with that
um I've got a new show that's been on
BBC then another show that I've got that
I'm going to be in very soon I've got my
book coming out I've got about four or
five hours a day of training that I need
to do I've got a game that's
commemorating my daughter's life and you
know it's going to be for a two-year
anniversary on the 5th of May at CBS
Arena where I used to be a pro
footballer there's just so many
different things on a day-to-day basis
that I feel like I speak to about you
know speak to about 30 to 50 people a
day I try and go party in my training I
try and compiling my recovery and if I
have time
you know I get a little bit of food in
between that and then you know I I sleep
truthfully four to five hours a night
before I'm up the next day out of bed
and ready to go again
um like I say for me the Steep thing
isn't
the sleep thing isn't like because I'm
trying to I'm setting my alarm not
getting up that's what time I get up
in fact it was even early this morning
it's probably about 20 past four I just
get up
it's not because I want to I'd love to
be able to sleep more I don't
then when I'm up
I always tell my management I say like
if
if I haven't got anything in that hour
book me something in you know if it's
Tuesday and you feel like Tuesday
Morning be my day off fill it up I don't
want the time I hate the time
I never think about I'm gonna book a
nice holiday I never think about you
know I'm gonna go for food this weekend
got a lovely trip coming your way up to
the architect say again you've got a
lovely trip coming your way up to the
arc that's holiday exactly that
and I think you know it's all just
stages I I'm not
I
will say this uh you know number one
I wouldn't came to be you know
a mental health expert
I wouldn't also claim to be the best
marathon runner or Ultraman Runner
I wouldn't say oh I've raised the most
money for charity
you know
I don't try and pretend that I'm the
toughest man in this world or
I don't try and make the most money what
I try and do is I try and do
what I feel is right for me
every single day
and I just speak honest open and
transparent about that
and hope that you know me speaking and
my openness can help as many people on
their Journeys as well
you've mentioned that you're not dating
at the moment yeah that's not something
that you're fussed with
have you ever considered whether you'd
have another child
it's um it's a difficult one
like I said to you before about the day
you think it's not
it's not like I'm gonna be naive and say
I'm never gonna have another kid I don't
know
at the minute I finally thought a bit
hard for a few different reasons
I'm a very loving person I've got a
massive heart you know
I have love and I have respect for every
single person that I meet on a
day-to-day basis but if you're my family
you're my baby
my love is uncontainable
now
for that reason
I think it would be hard for me to think
of having another child at the minute
and the reason is
they say that you know
you don't know how much you love
something until it's gone or you don't
know how much you're gonna miss
something until it's gone yeah
imagine that but you're fearing You're
Gonna Lose That something every second
of every single day
always like this is my daughter
all day
I wanted her you know I wanted to switch
places
it felt like I knew her for a hundred
years
and the fact that I thought I was going
to lose her every single second
multiplied My Love by a million
so it's not I believe that I feel like I
couldn't have another kid
I just feel that this current stage of
time it would be unfair for me to have
another child knowing that I wouldn't be
able to love it as much as I do Azalea
that's the honest truth
I haven't quite got my head around that
one yet
I like to be fair you know
and it's not animals a lot of animals
yeah but I couldn't have an animal
because I know that I couldn't give it
the time that it requires I would never
just have an animal to have it as a pet
I I love whatever is around me
you know and for me
I just think you it would be unfair on
the child at the minute for me to have
another child when I know that I
couldn't possibly love it as much as I
love my daughter
who's in the sky
I
very much appreciate your openness your
honesty
the difference from the last time that
we spoke to now is
very Stark
I don't want to say that
I don't know
what you went through is something that
would be wished on anyone but it
definitely seems like it's landed on if
it was going to be on someone
you seem to have the capacity to have
been able to deal with it
it would have been enough to have
crushed anybody and almost including
yourself
but coming out the other side
Alchemy is turning something that's
useless into gold
and that kind of seems what's happening
now
I very much appreciate you today thank
you very much if people want to keep up
to date with the stuff that you do if
they want to find out more about the
foundations
where should they come
so they can head to my Instagram which
is Mr Ashley Kane
m-r-a-s-h-l-e-y-c-a-i-n
and then to keep with the foundation
it's the Azalea foundation and azaleas
about a-z-a-y-l-i-a
gosh I appreciate you thank you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]